[Música]
buenos días a todos sea en realidad día
mañana tarde o noche cuando se pueda
escuchar esta conferencia
hablamos de reboot hablamos del reinicio
hablamos de revoluciones y hablamos de
cambios hablamos de un momento
trascendental para todos nosotros para
ser humano como decían antes para
repensar para reflexionar un punto de
inflexión importante y ahí entra estos
nidos que son nuestras unidades
de vivienda y entra también desde ahí la
oportunidad que nos brinda ha sido el
siglo 21 de conexión de generar unos
nodos de conexión a todos los niveles
en este momento pandémico que hemos
estado digamos encerrados hemos podido
conectarnos con nuestros mayores hemos
podido conectarnos con nuestras
amistades a nivel global continuarla a
la educación etcétera etcétera vamos a
hablar de rediseñar entornos y tenemos
que pensar cuál es nuestro entorno desde
luego el entorno es el planeta es el
mundo por supuesto y una nueva dimensión
del planeta que nos que tenemos que
vivir y que debemos vivir con un nuevo
compromiso con una nueva visión de
nuestra solidaridad y como decían antes
también por supuesto de una nueva
sostenibilidad está esta visión de una
ciudad de ciudades hacia la que vamos
según muchos sociólogos antropólogos y
visionarios por ejemplo una de ellas
saskia sassen se complementa también con
otra visión de nuestro entorno
muy cercano en esta visión de
countryside y ochos de red colas otro de
los grandes visionarios del futuro y
está estas dos dimensiones o muchas más
dimensiones que se cruzan un campo por
supuesto conectado un campo que da
nuevas unas nuevas posibilidades para el
ser humano para utilizar los recursos de
una forma mejor utilizar el campo o una
nueva dimensión de vida vamos y
comenzamos con este nido del que hablaba
en el título nuevos nidos y nodos porque
desde luego está este parón que hemos
tenido y ahora éste recomienzo reinicio
nos lleva también a una pulsión humana
que hemos vivido muy de cerca que es esa
incertidumbre esa inquietud de que iba a
suceder y de qué forma nos faltan
respuestas por supuesto porque estamos
en el proceso estamos todavía hoy no ha
pasado la pandemia estamos todavía
reflexionando analizando que tenemos a
nuestro alrededor
cómo actuar cómo interactuar como
mejorar nuestro entorno y desde luego si
mejoramos nuestro entorno podemos ir por
supuesto de lo global a lo local y de lo
local a los espacios íntimos y podemos
ir por supuesto de nuestra interacción
con el entorno más inmediato hacia la
acción global en este sentido hemos
tenido sentido hemos sentido esa pulsión
por la protección por cambiar volver a
anidar volver a recoger ramas diferentes
y constituir nuevos espacios de vida en
principio desde ese hogar nido en el que
nos hemos situado como punto como punto
de desarrollo de nuestras actividades y
de vida y con un factor que ha tomado
una relevancia muy espacial especial y
muy determinante que es el factor del
diseño el factor del diseño con el cruce
de todas las áreas del diseño pero
también con una dimensión que llega a lo
estratégico que llega al cambio de los
procesos y al cambio de los sistemas
sociales culturales pero también
empresariales cómo se trabaja de qué
forma se vuelve a pensar en los esquemas
y las fórmulas
de trabajo y de dimensión de la empresa
hacia dónde va empresas corporaciones o
instituciones
ahí está el diseño en este momento como
una confluencia de ideas de creatividad
desde diferentes aspectos y puntos de
vista que aportan soluciones por
supuesto la revolución de los espacios
interiores espacios y ese punto de
inflexión ese punto de reflexión tan
importante que hemos vivido que hemos
vivido en esta hibernación
donde hemos podido pensar sobre nosotros
sobre nuestra familia inmediata sobre
las personas con las que nos
conectábamos y pensar sobre todo también
en cuanto a la información que nos llega
y cómo devolverá y cómo tomar partido y
cómo poder ayudar también a rafael a
mejorar lo que nos rodea y de qué forma
es este proyecto está unido a escala
humana es un hotel diseñado hace hace
muy pocos años en suecia en los bosques
de hearts es decir es un gran éxito
porque todo el mundo quiere ir a estos
estos puntos elevarse y constituir y
tener esta sensación onírica o lírica de
este nido este nido también para
elevarse en una atalaya donde
en el futuro donde ver nuevos horizontes
por ejemplo vamos a ir aludiendo a
diferentes proyectos de diseño que nos
llevan al principio a lo conceptual este
diseñador español una de las grandes
figuras internacionales del diseño a
nacho carbonell lleva muchos años
trabajando sobre esta idea de influir
con un mensaje poderoso más allá por
supuesto de la funcionalidad es diseño
con lo cual conlleva función sino
también lanzar un mensaje y el con esta
pieza este arbusto que también es una
silla y que también es un un cubículo
para poderte concentrar lanza este
mensaje con estos filamentos también de
conexión con el exterior
ella es rosa norlan y una de las grandes
galeristas de diseño en milán con esta
este empuje también de apoyo al talento
él es el propio nacho carbonell que
desarrolla su trabajo desde eindhoven y
desde luego si hablamos de este aspecto
lírico hablamos también de una unidad
fundamental que somos nosotros con
nuestra con nuestra presencia física con
ese mensaje que lanzamos cada mañana
personal íntimo hacia el mundo con
nuestra manera de vestir más allá de la
moda más allá de los sistemas de la moda
que están también en una convulsión
constante en este momento que yo creo
que será muy beneficiosa para todos
tenemos por ejemplo estas diseñadoras
españolas esta diseñadora española
raquel buj arquitecta que nos formula
este mensaje desde el primero de
nuestros entornos que es nuestra piel
una ella investiga innova en los
materiales innova
desde la biodegradabilidad hasta la
sostenibilidad nuevos materiales que
mejoran nuestro cuerpo y mejoran nuestra
conexión también con los entornos esta
colección fue presentada hace
hace una semana escasa raquel burbuja
estudio del que llevó un niño muy
interesante con materiales
biodegradables muy avanzados anidar
saber quiénes somos
saber en qué momento nos encontramos y
hacia dónde vamos pero con una ventaja y
yo lo veo como una ventaja como un
renacimiento humano también a través de
los nodos de conexión a través de la
transformación digital lo que está claro
es que estamos en transición es muy
difícil analizar y llegar a conclusiones
determinantes cuando estás en un momento
de transición y de reflexión pero ahí
está también la revolución la
divergencia el debate anidar y volar
desde luego concentrarte pero tener
también la pulsión de estar conectados
de poder viajar si no es físicamente
digitalmente y unas prioridades que han
ido han ido posicionándose de una forma
muy clara en nuestra vida en este
momento por supuesto la salud nuestra y
la de nuestro entorno al bienestar
nuestro y el de nuestro entorno el
diseño hoy
específicamente una colección de piezas
de objetos no es solamente el diseño de
interiores no es solamente el diseño de
moda el diseño gráfico el diseño
audiovisual el diseño de la comunicación
como he dicho entra en estrategias entra
en otras fórmulas de cambio en conexión
con las corporaciones con las
instituciones políticas sociales y por
supuesto culturales es un cruce de áreas
es que llega al pensamiento de diseño es
el design thinking es el pensamiento de
diseño que influye tanto en los pequeños
cambios que estamos estamos
desarrollando desde nuestra posición
humana por supuesto la innovación que es
la innovación una palabra también
posiblemente muy gastada como es la
palabra sostenibilidad pero la
innovación es dar un paso más no
quedarte en lo que tienes siempre
intentar avanzar y no solamente crecer
por crecer sino evolucionar y por
supuesto esa sostenibilidad que en
realidad es equilibrio un balance de
todos los recursos precisamente hoy
es uno y nosotros mismos somos uno y
somos muchos somos múltiples hoy el
hogar lo sabemos perfectamente porque lo
utilizamos y hemos sentido esa necesidad
esa oficina es jardín hemos intentado de
introducir la naturaleza no solamente
con jardín con pequeños huertos es un
punto de reciclaje es nuestro centro de
reciclaje es un centro de deporte es un
centro también de reflexión e incluso un
templo donde meditar donde pensar
pues por supuesto están las iglesias
cerradas y es una iglesia
de cualquier adscripción religiosa
necesitábamos también un punto de
meditación en nuestro propio hogar
escuela se ha convertido en una escuela
en una universidad para nuestros hijos
pero para nosotros mismos y por supuesto
una zona de juegos y una zona también de
telecomunicaciones de ampliar todo lo
que hacemos hacia el exterior unidos
conectados nodos uno de los centros más
importantes del hogar y una de mis de
mis investigaciones es con el instituto
silestone de de cosentino es la cocina
como centro del hogar uno de ellos es la
unidad habitacional donde ya no
solamente se cocina y eso es un tema
apartado digamos de la vivienda sino que
se abre se expande y ahí se trabaja los
niños juegan es el centro de reciclaje
es el centro astronómico por supuesto en
el que participa toda la familia sea del
tipo que sea sea el número digamos de
miembros que sea pero como hemos visto
la divergencia también es muy
interesante hoy
las corrientes de pensamiento parten de
la divergencia de un punto máximo hacia
un lado y otro punto máximo y
alternativo hacia el otro
la investigadora arquitecta ana puigvert
desde la universidad de harvard presenta
este estudio tan interesante sobre
espacios sin cocina que sean servicios
comunales y comunitarios la cama la cama
como un espacio incluso arquitectónico
una investigación de beatriz colomina
para la universidad de princeton donde
vemos que la cama es un es un espacio y
de trabajo es un espacio de
telecomunicaciones es un espacio por
supuesto de descanso pero es un lugar
donde se realizan múltiples realizamos
todos múltiples múltiples también el
desayuno en la cama es decir los pasados
hoy se puede llevar a otros a otros
ámbitos incluso gastronómicos y así lo
presentaba beatriz colomina en el
pabellón de holanda de la última bienal
de arquitectura que tuvo lugar en la
foto está con andrés jaque otro de
nuestros grandes
y revolucionador es de la sociedad y de
los espacios en este momento el jugar
todo de baño otra unidad que cobra una y
mil dimensiones un espacio íntimo donde
encontrarte donde donde te reflejas
donde se refleja tu verdad corporal y
también donde se introducen nuevos
materiales nuevas nuevas puestas nuevos
jardines y también en la naturaleza no
solamente se representa a través de la
vegetación también se representa por
ejemplo a través de la de las
superficies de por ejemplo las de la
piedra natural por ejemplo el barro si
vamos a otros otros materiales más
artesanales la deconstrucción de los
espacios goes ambos una diseñadora
holandesa está cambiando las escuelas
las universidades está cambiando las
librerías está cambiando las bibliotecas
está cambiando los hogares también desde
darles un movimiento
pensamos distinto cuando nos sentamos de
forma diferente pensamos distinto si
estamos tumbados cuando estamos erguidos
la luz como un material que no podemos
tocar y que hemos aprendido que debemos
tener para cada acción del día debemos
tener una luz diferente antes pensábamos
una iluminación una lámpara y ahora en
este momento necesitamos digamos que
cada espacio conformar la artesanía
necesitamos nuevas envolvernos en nuevos
tejidos aquí tenemos un proyecto de hilo
emma de antonio ballester necesita este
proyecto de también de nuevos materiales
no solamente digamos de la tradición y
de las raíces y de la artesanía sino
también de la alta tecnología llevado a
los textiles que nos envuelven las
sábanas las toallas los tejidos de los
paz y los espejos por ejemplo otra
corriente interesantísima que amplifican
los espacios donde nos reflejamos
nosotros y amplifican también la vida en
nuestra casa ese proyecto era de una
empresa de martelly
los núcleos burbujas que nos digamos y
separadores entre la casa para generar
espacios muy diferentes para cada
actividad este por ejemplo proyecto de
estudio banana
nos puede acompañar y generando un
espacio íntimo personal de sueño o de
concentración
muy diferente y acabó
yéndome a una unidad interior de quiénes
somos y cómo nos proyectamos es una obra
artística de anna rierola junto con
diferentes institutos científicos de
todo el mundo para representar nuestro
interior humano son células son
bacterias y son un jardín nuestro jardín
interior así somos por dentro y así
estamos conectados en uno solo en uno
solo como ser humano y en un todo
múltiple dependiendo digamos de las
actividades y de nuestra dimensión más
humana más comprometida y como un
renacimiento que estamos reiniciando en
este momento muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]